hello everyone and welcome to a really
really nice game I played between maxime
beaugeois grab and myself
congratulations to those of you who
found this video via the links in the
podcast but if you still haven't seen
the podcast do check it out the links to
it the link to it will be in the
description below and basically the
links there are links to various
platforms so basically why I played
against MDL I asked him if he was
interested in after we finished with the
podcast the plate 1 5 minute blitz game
that I can show on my channel afterwards
and he said yeah sure no problem and
this is a this is a one such game and I
prepared for the game not a lot but it
did prepare I prepared an eider with the
white pieces and I also prepared the
night off with the black pieces so I was
I was very unhappy when I Maxine played
Knight to f3 and the first move he went
for the other for the reopening and ok
I played the d5 as I usually do and here
he went c4 and I replied with Knight to
f6 now it's it's better to go d4 or east
6 because Knight to f6 I was planning to
go e6 next move but it seems that you
can already take advantage of this
imprecise move order which Maxime did he
played a C characters on d5 we have
Knight captures on d5 by me and now II
four already gaining time by attacking
the knight I played Knight b6 and he
went to d4 so already white has
excellent control of the center and the
black has well somewhat suspicious night
here on b6 ok I play d6 and not allowing
the 5 that he played Knight to c3 and I
went to Bishop to b4 again maybe not not
the the greatest continuation but this
whole this whole line with developing
the knight on f6 and the second move is
already very very very risky obviously
he went to Bishop to d3 just nicely
continuing development and I Castle he
also castled and there is one game in
the database here where h6 was played it
was played between Kasparov and Bora in
1980 1830 which was part 1 in a very
nice miniature but I went a bunch of
characters in C 3 here he recaptured and
I went to Knight to c6 I thought about
going c5 but then e 5 and it's just
for white he has a nice control of d4 so
it's not really causing him any problems
so I went and Knight to c6 with with the
idea of maybe shifting the night over to
the Kings side to help out with the
defense as I am expecting him to play e5
which he of course did he opened up this
bishops diagonal with ideas so for Queen
e2 Queen e4 and just going for mate but
also there is the the instant Bishop
captures on h7 threat so here I played
h6 trying to prevent that point is that
if I go something like a bishop d7 then
this is just winning for white captures
captures and check and after you go back
just queen h5 will be winning there's no
there's no stopping this and even if you
go to g6 it's still winning for white
let's say h4 and then there's no defense
against h5 you will have to go to h6 but
I can let's say whatever you play h5 you
go here Knight captures with with our
discover to check and you lose the Queen
for example so here I played h6 and
maxime made a little remark he said oh
someone knows his classics saying that I
didn't blunder the Bishop captures on h7
sacrifice so now I survived for a bit
longer
he went Queen e2 he wants to go Queenie
for and checkmate me and it's really
really it's nearly impossible to play
this position it's just remarkable how
miss playing the move order and the
second move just gives you such such a
tremendously bad position and it was a
like I said it was a five minute blitz
game but I first I really started
bleeding out moves but I was kind of
really nervous of course I mean who
wouldn't be and then I stopped for a
little bit but then or when I started
thinking about the position and what was
going on I was very I was already in a
pretty pretty bad spot so here I played
Knight to d5 with the idea that if
Queenie 4 I can survive with f5 meaning
if he captures I can capture on f6
attacking his Queen and defending the h7
square so he just played Bishop d2 I
continued development he also defended
the c3 pawn now he's preparing c4 to
kick away the night and then he can go
Queenie 4 with some some nice threats so
here I play tonight cita east 7
if Queen comes to e4 then I can still
block it with Knight to g6 although it's
not not the greatest of plans
he played c4 kick my not away I went
back to b6 and he played a for not even
not even a rushing with Queenie for I
just going after a5 not to giving my
knight any squares so basically playing
playing with his food
I played 85 not allowing a 5-4 white and
he played rook F to be one I played
Knight to c6 and you can see that it's
it's such a bad position for black my
queen and Bishop doing nothing both
roses doing nothing the Knights are on
the Queen side where when all the action
is happening on the Kings side here so
he played Queen e4 finally now
threatening Queen to h7 checkmate and
there really is no way to deal with this
you can go f5 and then maybe try and
hide your King over to the Queen side
but of course it will not work so I
played g6 instead I gave up the h6 pawn
but it it does not really help the
bishop captures rook e8 and he played
Bishop to g5 attacks my queen but
basically wants to set up a mating net
here with Bishop f6 and queen to h8 I
went to Queen to d7 and he went Queen to
h4 now the idea is Bishop f6 fall by
checkmate
so I played f5 stop not allowing it so
now at least my Queen has access to the
h7 square but by doing so I allow each
captures an f6 alpha song and there's
nothing more to be done here now like if
I if I go let's say queen h7 over a
queen trade I'm still down 2 points so
if you want to even help me if I survive
the attack but he can just block and
well next move he's gonna play Queen g5
he's gonna capture on g6 and so on so I
played Queen to f7 not allowing him to
push the pawn but here he played Queen
to h6 and it was in this position that I
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so point is he's
preparing to capture on g6 and even if I
try and trade Queens here it's still not
possible he can just go f7 check I
cannot capture because they lose the
Queen if Queen captures
then he can go Bishop captures here
let's say I go for a queen trade he can
just trade pick up the rook but he
doesn't even have to go for 4 material
you can just you know avoid trading
Queens and it
we'll be checkmate very soon so after
Queen to h6 I resigned the game and well
it was quite the game basically this is
what it looks like to be completely
outclassed and beyond but on the plus
side it it inspired me to take up a
course maybe under 80 and learn a little
bit because here in the beginning I
didn't really think about it at all I
played d5 and after this c4 I played
Knight to f6 you know trying to get to
get a normal setup but I didn't take
into consideration that the dish just
gives him a lot of time to create a huge
center and just well it it all just went
downhill from here
but yeah it's a move order is very
important as you've seen here and yeah I
definitely think I'm gonna take a crash
course under Ettie not to be able to
survive at least until move to yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said do check out the podcast the
links will be in the description below
and also here is a message from a
mystery person regarding the podcast so
here it is let's check it out
everyone can you guess who that person
is correct it's me MDL and hello
everyone and I wanted to welcome you to
the podcast with again matter that I did
yesterday and we had a great talk I hope
you guys would enjoy it thanks so there
you have it you are invited to check out
the podcast by both Maxime and myself
and I really do hope you enjoy it it's a
it's only some 2 hours long so if you
have 2 hours to spare do check it out I
would also like to thank Angela Grover
Tom mckarrick trevor henry girl Gora
Gora as the ratchet and christopher bet
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga and whatever else happens in the
chess world and i also forgot forgot to
mention even though it was a five minute
blitz game it took Maxine some 40
seconds to play this game so he still
had like four minutes and
20 seconds and I was I was down to like
a minute and a half when I resigned yeah
thank you all and I will see you soon